en Francia los manifestantes siguen en
las calles contra la reforma de las
pensiones promovida por el gobierno del
presidente Emmanuel
pese algunas concesiones El Ejecutivo
estaría aún lejos de cumplir con las
demandas de los manifestantes
[Música]
vamos a aguantar mientras aguanta el
gobierno siempre estaremos ahí esperando
que ceda llevamos tres días Seguiremos
Yo estoy aquí por solidaridad Es cierto
que me beneficio de una pensión que
pagan todos los que trabajan pero
también Lucho porque otros antes que yo
lucharon por este derecho
la ampliación del período de cotización
sigue siendo el principal punto de
discordia según el gobierno la reforma
debe salvar el sistema de pensiones que
estaría indet pero este argumento es
rechazado por los sindicatos
creo que La retórica del gobierno ha
cambiado hemos pasado de una reforma de
Justicia social y progreso social a una
reforma imprescindible sino es la
quiebra de no sé qué cuando oigo a los
miembros de la mayoría de decir que el
déficit alcanzaría los 300 mil millones
no sé dónde lo han leído Sí el gobierno
está acorralado se está quedando sin
argumentos está intentando asustar a la
gente
en la asamblea nacional los debates
agitados sobre el proyecto de reforma
comenzaron esta semana el ministro de
trabajo
Se declaró listo para hacer unas mejoras
al texto los miembros del partido de
Centro derecha los republicanos están
divididos en cuanto al proyecto pero su
apoyo será decisivo para evitar que el
gobierno utilice el 49 3 un artículo de
la Constitución que le permitiría
aprobar el texto sin votación mientras
el tiempo para encontrar un compromiso
se está acabando la primera ministra
Elizabeth bone fijo 27 de febrero como
fecha límite para el examen del texto
por la asamblea